[Musique]
c'est une une famille avec plusieurs
enfants ils sont dans la montagne en
restaurant en altitude il va y avoir ce
qu'on appelle une avalanche contrôlée
donc ce sont des gens qui vont
déclencher une avalanche sauf que cette
avalanche contre
[Musique]
il va arriver au rang de ce restaurant
en altitude dans lequel est la famille à
ce moment-là le père prend son portable
cours se protéger et la mer saute sur
les enfants à ce moment-là on arrive sur
un drame familial
[Musique]
il y a ce qu'on appelle un non dit tout
au long du film très très peu de
dialogue mais je pense ça a été un des
premiers films sur lequel le silence est
une règle d'or et elle le plus présent
dans le cinéma mondial
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la règle du père
protecteur qui éclate on peut parler
concrètement de hors-piste du cinéma
avec une musique en fait qui revient
régulièrement qui est la
musique de l'hiver des Quatre Saisons de
Vivaldi et qui est l'unique musique qui
est utilisé au sein de ce film c'est un
travail sur le comportement humain et de
ses réactions un effondrement du couple
du silence qui pose lourd un
renforcement sur eux-mêmes sur les
personnages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu l'horreur du réel et on
peut parler concrètement d'une
expérience sociale
[Musique]